[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur public
c'est la 90 minutes pour donner du sens
à l'actualité et l'actu de ce 20 juin
c'est la visite de Georgia Meloni en
France la chef du gouvernement italien
issu de l'ultra-droite conservatrice
chrétienne souverainiste peut-elle
s'entendre avec un évènement qu'elle a
plusieurs fois attaqué avant et après
son arrivée au pouvoir quels sont les
intérêts communs qui peuvent forcer un
rapprochement malgré les divergences
politiques comment Georgia Meloni
peut-elle peser dans une Union
européenne dont elle critiquent les
institutions réponses dans une minute et
puis pour notre seconde débat c'est dans
le sillage de Laurent Berger que je vous
emmène le syndicalisme est de retour il
est de retour pas simplement dans la rue
il est retour dans les entreprises il
est retour dans les chiffres de de
d'adhérents
[Musique]
n'est pas convié et elle le prend très
mal
[Musique]
si j'avais été invité à l'Elysée pour la
rencontre avec Zellen ski j'aurais
conseillé de ne pas faire cette réunion
pourquoi parce que s'agissant de
l'Ukraine ce qui nous intéresse avant
tout c'est de donner un message
d'unités
de jouer sa propre partition au niveau
européen candidate elle critiquait
Bruxelles et vantait le modèle
réceptique de Victor Hormann une fois au
pouvoir elle entame un virage plus
favorable à lieu alignez notamment avec
les autres capitales européennes dans
son soutien à l'Ukraine n'a pas
forcément d'influence politique en
Europe mais elle n'est pas marginalisée
elle ne remet pas en cause
l'appartenance à l'euro à ne pas en
cause les sanctions européennes qu'on
soit Russie contraire à les défends elle
est pour l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne elle est pour une
zone euro forte donc elle ne sait pas du
tout marginalisée elle ne peut pas
d'ailleurs se faire de le faire puisque
l'Italie dépend énormément des fonds
européens et de du plan de relance
européen chef d'un gouvernement
nationaliste et ultra conservateur
George ameloni poursuit ses efforts de
normalisation à moins d'un an des
élections européennes la présidente du
Conseil italien tente un rapprochement
avec le Parti populaire européen qui
rassemble les droites de gouvernement en
Europe je vous présente tout de suite
mes invités pour ce premier débat
Ludmila connaît bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes historienne spécialiste de l'Italie
médiévale et contemporaine chercheuse
associée à l'Université Paris 1 Alberto
Toscano bonsoir et bienvenue journaliste
écrivain italien Pascal Joana bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
directrice générale de la Fondation
Schuman j'accueille avec nous en duplex
Marc Lazare professeur d'histoire et de
sociologie politique à Sciences Po et
vous êtes président de la School of
gouvernement de l'université Luis a Rome
bienvenue à vous et
compagnie visant Emmanuel Macron non les
gars une grande attente mais il y a
aussi la certitude du fait que les
éléments qui poussent vers l'accord sont
beaucoup plus importants et solides des
éléments qui poussent vers la polémique
qui a commencé par ces phrases un peu un
peu brutale du ministre de l'Intérieur
Darmanin au sujet de l'immigration
l'immigration a un problème commun et
les parfaitement inutile il y avait eu
aussi enfin on va pas refaire la bagarre
de polémique l'important qu'aujourd'hui
il y a des bonnes raisons pour
s'entendre et bien surtout deux sujets
sur lesquels France et Italie ont déjà
aujourd'hui une entente solide c'est
l'Ukraine et le pacte de stabilité
européenne qui doit être relancé
reformuler et au sujet duquel France et
Italie ont une attitude commune assez
déterminée vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne
évidemment Pascal Joanin vous dites quoi
enfin il était temps qu'il y a une vraie
rencontre il s'était croisé rapidement
mais il était temps oui enfin oui enfin
ça fait 8 mois que Madame Meloni est
arrivé aux affaires alors on se souvient
que le Président de la République était
opportunément à Rome le jour où elle
avait prêté serment qu'ils étaient
brièvement rencontrés on avait dit tiens
c'est plutôt de bonne augure il va y
avoir
un courant qui va se passer puisqu'il
est relativement jeune lui aussi donc ça
pouvait ça pouvait le faire c'était un
peu le hasard il était en Italie ce
jour-là alors qu'on sait que il faut se
traiter des choses en commun depuis le
départ du Royaume-Uni l'Italie et les
trois grands pays de l'Union c'est un
pays fondateur on a des points communs
en matière économique des points communs
sur les questions comme vous l'avez dit
de règle économiques enfin on a un
certain nombre de choses à régler et
donc ne passe parler c'était vraiment
donc c'est une c'est une c'est une sage
décision qu'ils seront Marc Lazare on
dit ne passe parler et c'est vrai que
c'est c'était ce que renvoyait les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement sauf que
derrière on évidemment les diplomates
travaillent ça s'est jamais il y a
toujours eu des des fils de dialogue
cette rencontre effectivement elle a été
préparée depuis des mois elle a été
préparée depuis des mois par
l'ambassadeur de France en Italie par
l'ambassadrice d'Italie à Paris par les
ministères des Affaires étrangères par
les conseillers diplomatiques qui
voulaient à tout prix que cette
rencontre ait lieu je remarque que c'est
pas une visite officielle que c'est à
l'occasion de sa venue pour l'expo à
Rome candidature que d'ailleurs ne
soutient pas la France
qu'elle est venue avec le maire de Rome
qui est un maire de gauche Roberto
boitieri je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit mais
j'introduirai une nuance de fond c'est à
dire que je crois que c'est absolument
une nécessité pour les deux
gouvernements d'avoir justement cette
rencontre et de mettre sur la table les
sujets sur lesquels il y a des
convergences mais aussi les sujets
notamment l'immigration sur lequel il y
a une profonde divergence parce que l'un
et l'autre ont besoin chacun d'entre eux
mais d'autre part il y a un désaccords
de fond et ce désaccord de fond il va
surgir à l'occasion des élections
européennes il est déjà là parce qu'il y
a décision complètement différente de
l'Union européenne mais vraiment de
vision totalement antagonique celle de
président Macron s'il y a un fil rouge
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 alors
qu'il a changé sur beaucoup de sujets
c'est l'Europe et il y a un fil rouge
chez Giorgia Meloni ou plus exactement
il y a un changement elle n'est plus
contre l'Europe et elle est dans
l'Europe pour la changer au profit d'une
dimension plus nationale de l'Europe et
donc il y aura de nouveau des tensions
le Mila connait vous êtes d'accord
là-dessus ça veut dire que le ce duo se
coupe franco-italien il va forcément
être obligé de d'avancer un peu encrable
même s'il y a des intérêts importants
c'est l'Union européenne c'est
nécessaire c'est on peut pas faire
autrement en même temps évidemment je
suis d'accord avec ma classeur il y a
des divergences profondes les divisions
opposées sur l'Europe et aussi sur notre
sujet donc ces questions elles vont
forcément surgir et quand notamment
aussi sur des questions de démocratie et
des droits des droits sociétaux est-ce
que aujourd'hui
non bien sûr aujourd'hui oui ça on va on
va vouloir donner une image de de
aujourd'hui échauffement c'est ce que
disait marcassa tôt ou tard enfin il
faut un moment donné apparaître parce
qu'ils sont là et c'est sont vraiment
des conceptions opposées alors
un autre sujet de divergence qui est
peut-être petit par rapport à l'Europe
la Grande Europe le grand histoires mais
quand même significatif parce que le
fait que Manuel Macron soutient la
candidature de Riad de l'Arabie Saoudite
pour l'organisation pour héberger
l'exposition universelle de 2030 au
détriment de la ville de Rome qui est si
engagée et d'ailleurs c'est la raison
pour les prétexte du voyage de Madame
melonia Paris où il y a le siège du
Bureau international des expositions
dont cet élément est un révélateur quand
même d'une attitude française qui est
vous êtes désagréable et je pense du
point de vue italien
les Italiens ont du mal vraiment à
comprendre comment est-ce que c'est
possible et quels sont les dynamiques
qui amènent l'Elysée a soutenir la
candidature d'un pays qui n'est pas
européen et qui je crois n'est pas
tellement démocratie que ce soit un
modèle de démocratie effectivement parce
qu'à Johan est-ce que c'est un mauvais
coup ça ou une petite vengeance certains
diront mesquine d'un Emmanuel Macron qui
a pas accepté d'être critiqué par
Georgia mélodie je vais pas soutenir la
candidature de Rome après après avoir
été à ce point critiquer complètement
anachronique de soutenir une une
candidature d'une ville qui n'est pas
européenne qui a une deuxième ville qui
est européenne c'est Odessa mais bon qui
est en guerre donc ça sera peut-être
plus compliqué mais en 2030 mais au-delà
des shikayas il y a quand même
le la raison d'être à quoi dire qu'on a
on a un mouvement de fond qui est plus
puissant on a besoin de parler avec
l'Italie et donc
les petites phrases les les choses qui
sont dites comme ça etc ça ne fait pas
avancer les choses or on a besoin y
compris sur les migrations parce que sur
la migration la France et l'Allemagne ne
sont la France et l'Italie ne sont pas
aussi éloignées l'une que l'autre
puisque en effet si l'Italie reçoit
beaucoup plus de migrants que la France
ils sont tous les deux d'accord pour
qu'il y ait une répartition au niveau
européen ce que certains États ne
veulent pas ça je vous interrompre sur
l'éman sur l'immigration parce qu'on va
y consacrer un chapitre entier un peu
plus tard dans ce débat mais je voudrais
rester sur cette idée d'un d'un
partenariat un peu un peu obligatoire de
toute façon et c'est finalement
se donner par Marc Lazare tout à l'heure
de dépasser les obstacles mais c'est un
peu ce que nous disait le porte-parole
du gouvernement tout simplement Olivier
Véran ce matin sur cnews l'Italie c'est
un partenaire économique majeur voilà
notre deuxième partenaire économique
c'est notre frère européen ce sont nos
voisins il y a des villes françaises
comme la mienne Grenoble qui sont
irrigués par l'histoire italienne et
donc évidemment qu'on a envie de
progresser avec l'Italie les annonces
qui ont été faites sur le lion Turin par
exemple en développer du fer routage
entre la France et l'Italie montre
atteste s'il était besoin que notre
relation sont aussi fortes avec les
Italiens qu'elles lancées par le passé
il y a eu un autre exemple là à
l'occasion du Salon du Bourget avec ce
système de de défense
anti-aériens franco-italien annonce
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est déployé en
Ukraine le Mila connaît il y a ces
intérêts économiques on peut peut-être
faire un peu d'histoire quoi c'est le
fruit d'un d'un voisinage devenu de plus
en plus fructueux économiquement on peut
dire ça ça fait très longtemps que les
Italiens les Français ont des intérêts
communs ne serait-ce que
géographiquement il y a des familles
entières qui sont franco-italiennes il y
a vraiment une proximité mais culturelle
je parle que ça soit le patrimoine le
tourisme la mise du territoire s'il y a
des choses tout à fait importante à ce
niveau là évidemment comme on le disait
on viendra sur la question de
l'immigration mais
il y a aussi un peu de rivalité il faut
pas l'oublier et un petit peu de
rivalité à qui passe en premier à la
voilà il y a cet aspect qui a toujours
et de les cousins Italiens les cousins
français ça existe aussi mais quand on
est dans un même bateau en ce qui
concerne l'économie et la coopération il
faut quand même essayer de avancer il y
a une date qui se profile à l'horizon
dans très peu de temps 29 30 juin marque
laser le Conseil européen on l'a évoqué
très vite avec Alberto Toscano il y a
cet enjeu du pacte de enfin des règles
de stabilité budgétaire elles ont
explosé avec la crise covid il faut les
réinventer et les rétablir et est-ce
qu'on peut dire que là-dessus marque
Lazar il y a des intérêts communs entre
nos deux pays effectivement
oui non oui c'est évident c'est
là-dessus qu'il y a un intérêt commun à
la France à l'Italie et c'est pas par
hasard que le communiqué de l'Élysée qui
annonce la visite qui a annoncé la
visite de Giorgia Meloni précisez bien
que c'était dans la perspective entre
autres du Conseil européen la France a
besoin de l'Italie il y a tous les
intérêts économiques et commerciaux qui
viennent d'être rappelés mais là il y a
une bataille commune par rapport à ce
qu'on appelle les pays frugaux par
rapport au ministre de l'économie
allemande la France a besoin d'Italie
donc plus exactement je vais être un peu
cynique la France se rappelle qu'elle a
besoin de l'Italie dans ces cas-là et
donc effectivement il faut agir ça sera
pas la première fois lors de du
gouvernement de Giuseppe conté 1
c'est-à-dire un moment où il y a une
crise diplomatique entre Paris et Rome
nous avons rappelé notre ambassadeur
Christian Masset à Paris pendant une
semaine ça ne s'était pas fait depuis
1940 c'est à dire la déclaration de
guerre de Mussolini à la France malgré
ça elle était exactement la même période
au moment du conseil
et Emmanuel Macron s'était retrouvé
ensemble au Conseil européen pour agir
ensemble ça c'est continuer avec Mario
Draghi on a évoqué Mario Draghi avec
Mario Draghi c'était la lune de miel là
c'est pas la lune de miel ils sont
obligés de trouver une entente donc oui
c'est un aimant très important et en
plus il y a des lobbies qui agissent
dans ce sens-là
l'organisation du méthaf l'organisation
patronale un rapport très étroit avec la
confine industrie à qui est une
organisation patronale encore plus
puissante que le Medef du fait de sa
structure du fait de son implantation
dans le pays c'est tenu récemment ici à
Rome d'où je vous parle une rencontre
comme il y en a chaque année il y a eu
un communiqué commun qui dit en gros qui
rappelle au gouvernant l'importance des
relations économiques et commerciales et
la nécessité justement d'avoir une
politique commune donc voilà tous ces
éléments sont prises en considération
par des gouvernements il y a des
divergences politiques profondes
évidemment elle
un trou encore une fois dans la
perspective des élections européennes
mais il y a un intérêt qui est à la fois
bilatéral un intérêt de chaque pays et
espère les gouvernements français
italien l'intérêt comme un pour l'Europe
Laetitia va se tourner sur les enjeux
mais alors côté Emmanuel Macron parce
que cette rencontre avec Georgia Meloni
a le place un petit peu en position
d'équilibriste expliquez-nous pourquoi
parce qu'Emmanuel Macron s'adresse à
deux publics distincts il s'adressent
assez partenaires européens aux
européens mais aussi aux Français on va
commencer d'abord par l'Europe puisque
c'est vrai que c'est le premier public
le plus le plus évident alors vous avez
beau dire que la presse italienne nuance
un peu cette rencontre moi j'ai trouvé
dans la République à quand même qui
écrit aujourd'hui 7 mois de tension
d'affrontement de silence et
d'accusation mutuelle dont les dont les
façons seront difficiles à éminer
effectivement pourtant vous regardez
vont déjà écouter le message qui
Emmanuel Macron va délivrer et que
Georgia Meloni va délivrer également
mais ils vont aussi scruter ce qu'on
appelle le non-verbal vous savez leurs
attitudes et puis peut-être aussi
quelques mots qui vont échapper ici et
là vous savez bien il y a cette souvent
une déclaration au pupitre officiel et
puis ensuite il y a les Microtus à la
presse donc ça va être vraiment on va
focaliser sur sur cette rencontre sur le
nom verbale on peut se souvenir de du 22
octobre dernier c'est ça exactement
cette photo alors qui est vraiment
fait tour de tous les médias c'était la
rencontre vous avez dit que Manuel
Macron était à Rome il a profité pour
aller féliciter je leur dis à Mélanie
qui venait de prêter serment et puis
alors cette photo où on les voyait
crisper vraiment il y avait une tension
palpable des sourires comme ça de façade
et c'était beaucoup amusé à sur les
réseaux à vraiment commenté cette cette
photographie et puis ensuite ils se sont
revus Thomas parce que cette crise
diplomatique à la crise autour la
question migratoire mais ils se sont
revus à Hiroshima en marge du G20 on en
a moins parlé c'était un aparté pourquoi
on en a moins parlé parce que les
Européens quoi qu'il arrive retiennent
encore aujourd'hui et un retienne encore
aujourd'hui c'est clash entre Gérald
Darmanin et puis Jordan Meloni on l'a
évoqué il y a il y a un terrain
d'entente qui va s'exprimer
officiellement aujourd'hui ça c'est sûr
en Ukraine ils sont d'accord et le volet
le volet économique et puis bien sûr les
relations bilatées
France-Italie parce que bien sûr que ces
deux pays ont des intérêts communs mais
surtout il faut toujours rappeler il me
semble pour un chef d'État français et
pour un chef du gouvernement italien
l'histoire et ce sont deux alliés
historiques et puis alors donc il y a ce
message là c'était le message européen
le message destiné aux Français et là
que ça se complique un peu pourquoi les
Français parce que on va dire que pour
la majorité d'entre nous George et
hameloni égal Marine Le Pen c'est la
Marine Le Pen italienne donc on va le
scruter là parce qu'il n'y aura pas de
message de déclaration officielle donc
il y aura beaucoup de non-verbal et on
va regarder un peu ce qui se dit comment
ils se comportent là avec avec l'autre
et si vous voulez dans les médias je
prends le pari avec vous je pense que ce
sera largement commenté ce soir avec une
question comment Emmanuel Macron se
comporte avec Georgia Meloni est-ce que
le chef d'État français est complaisant
avec cette femme qui s'est à un moment
de sa vie réclamer du fascisme vous
voyez pourquoi c'est un exercice
d'équilibriste pourquoi parce que le
message d'entente cordial qui va être
donné qui va être lancée aux Européens
peut-être ici mal interprété alors
justement et ça ouvre une partie du
débat vraiment centré sur Giorgia Meloni
et peut-être son son histoire Alberto
Toscano programme
ultra-droit de conservatrice chrétienne
souverainiste est-ce que ça en fait une
femme d'extrême droite comment elle est
caractérisée je pense que vous avez
absolument raison les problèmes avec il
y a sous-entendu du point de vue
français du point de vue d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que dédouaner signifie
dédouaner Marine Le Pen dont il y a ce
réflexe de politique intérieure
française qui complique ce dialogue mais
aujourd'hui malgré tout et on l'a dit et
tout le monde l'a dit les facteurs qui
poussent à l'entente réchauffement de la
relation sont nettement préalables et je
crois que
cet élément de
53 et un élément qu'on doit juger dans
la réalité des choses une fois qu'on a
dit qu'il n'y a pas de danger pour la
démocratie parce que moi je suis à Paris
depuis 37 ans et quand et Berluscon a
gagné la première fois tout le monde a
dit la démocratie italienne risque être
détruite ensuite il a perdu les heures
élection il a perdu le pouvoir et la
même pas perdu les élections et perdu le
pouvoir a besoin de perdre de direction
la première fois donc une fois qu'on a
dit que la démocratie italienne n'est
pas en danger hein et c'est important de
le dire il y a c'est sûr c'est sûr comme
c'est sûr pour la démocratie française
pour la démocratie allemande c'est sûr
exactement comme pour chacun de nos pays
de l'Union européenne les facteurs qui
poussent la défense de la démocratie
sont beaucoup plus importants que les
dangers le 90 on juge les politiques la
politique de George est certainement une
politique avec beaucoup d'erreurs de
problèmes notamment par exemple sur la
politique de la famille aujourd'hui en
Italie il y a des polémiques sur la
réforme de la justice il y a sans doute
des éléments de sa politique qui
provoquent des doutes et des critiques
elle est en train de renouveler quand
même les services publics et elle est en
train d'enlever toutes les personnalités
de gauche et de mettre des licences
d'un chat pays France comprise il y a un
spoil System qui est je crois qu'on est
dans la norme dans un contexte
relativement normal de r alors que
chaque nouveau gouvernement peut
commettre alors est-ce que vous êtes
toutes et tous d'accord avec ça je vous
donne la parole en premier le Mila à
connait est-ce que et je repose la
question qui est un peu binaire mais
pardon je simplifie les choses et est-ce
qu'elle est d'extrême droite est-ce
qu'on dit encore ça en Italie ou pas
c'est difficile à dire tout d'abord je
voulais quand même revenir sur Marine Le
Pen je trouve que Marine Le Pen elle est
encore modérée par rapport à Georgia
Meloni hein vous voyez et bien sur le
front sur les mais en tout état de cause
la politique des deux femmes et des deux
coalitions les deux parties elle est
aussi au fur et en mesure elle change
aussi selon les contingences et il est
clair que depuis au pouvoir avec sa
coalition on n'a jamais vu autant de
manifestations de réhabilitation franche
de symboles fasciste
et aussi d'attaque contre les droits
civiques le dernier en date c'est la
volonté d'un tribunal de enlever la
l'état civil d'enfants nés de
procréation médicalement assistée à
l'étranger de propriétaire
donc par procuration certes ce sont des
enfants on peut dire qu'un Italie ça
n'existe pas mais ce sont des enfants à
qui on enlève un droit fondamental et
tout ça c'est irrigué par l'idéologie du
parti nomméonie et de sa coalition donc
il ne faut pas est-ce que vous dites que
la démocratie italienne est en danger je
cherche pas à vous mettre en désaccord
l'un avec l'autre mais est-ce que vous
êtes aussi il y a des attaques très très
fortes contre des droits fondamentaux et
contre le fait même qu'un ministre de
l'Agriculture d'accord mais de dire
qu'il faut se battre contre
l'immigration pour éviter le
remplacement ethnique c'est quand même
quelque chose voilà je sens commente pas
c'est une connerie mais c'est pas une
attaque la démocratie c'est chaque
connerie un attaque à la démocratie dans
chaque pays il y a plein de conneries
dans le débat politique je ne sais pas
si moi je me je disais quelque chose
comme ça je ça n'aurai pas l'histoire de
l'Italie aussi
chaque pays a son histoire mais chacun
doit assumer ses bêtises dans les débats
politiques c'est plein de bêtises et là
c'est le Ministre
des responsabilités alors Pascal sur ce
parallèle Marine Le Pen Georgia mélodie
je crois que c'est il faut pas le faire
d'abord parce que Marine Le Pen
elle-même
a dit que George jameloni s'était pas sa
copine
je rappelle qu'elle ne siège pas dans le
même groupe au Parlement européen que
l'Allier de Marine Le Pen en Italie
c'est Matteo Salvini et la Lega
qui participe au gouvernement alors on a
en France quelque chose qui s'est passé
avec Macron qui était qui a été élu en
étant ni de droite ni de gauche et de
droite de gauche qu'on a pas retrouvé
ailleurs mais la coalition de centre
droit comme elle s'appelle
officiellement avec en effet Forza
Italia qui était le centre droit la Lega
qu'elle l'extrême droite et puis
dans les conservateurs européens
ça n'est pas transposable ailleurs on
n'a pas encore d'autres exemples en
effet réussi à faire ce truc et en effet
Forsa Italia dans le dans le président
historique est mort il y a pas longtemps
avait fait une coalition déjà avec
l'extrême droite mais il était le parti
fort alors que là c'est fratelliale
quelle partie fort mais il y a pas il y
a pas et le renversement dans Marc
Lazare vous pouvez prendre l'année
prochaine au Parlement européen c'est
pas maths c'est pas Marine Le Pen mais
elle a dit Marine Le Pen d'à côté et
d'abord elle est même pas au Parlement
européen c'est Bardella et elle elle est
la présidente d'un parti européen qui
s'appelle ECF et elle veut rassembler
des droites qui sont radicales mais qui
ne sont pas extrêmes et qui sont
monsieur
de renverser la table en créant une
force de droites
un peu radicale avec des parties qui ont
un peu le vent en poupe enfin lent en
Suède etc mais qui siège aujourd'hui
dans ce groupe c'est le modèle qu'elle a
bâti en Italie n'est pas transposable
d'ailleurs et on le verra en Pologne au
mois d'octobre mais il y a des éléments
qui sont quand même perturbants puisque
les leaders du rassemblement national
ici même jouent de cette de ce voisinage
on va dire avec Georgia Meloni on écoute
tiens par exemple Jordan Bardella le
président du Rassemblement national
c'était sur Europe 1
Jordan Bardella tout de suite
vous savez que madame eloni est en
coalition avec l'un de nos alliés que
j'ai rencontrés il y a quelques jours à
Rome Matteo Salvini qui est l'ancien
ministre de l'Intérieur qui avait réussi
pour le coup à faire baisser les
arrivées sur les côtes italienne qui est
aujourd'hui ministre des Infrastructures
mais en tout cas je suis un soutien de
Madame Meloni de Monsieur Salvini et je
crois que l'Italie doit être soutenue
dans la crise migratoire à laquelle elle
fait face parce que encore une fois les
migrants qui entrent en Italie seront
demain et après-demain en France ils
nous ne reprenons pas le contrôle
d'entend par démocratie on peut dire
est-ce que il ne sait pas il n'y a eu
pas d'effondrement de la démocratie avec
perlusconi il y a eu un retraitissement
progressif dans la démocratie avec
Berlusconi et notamment conflit
d'intérêt notamment rétrécissement du
droit de la représentativité y compris
syndicale un problème de de colle de de
monopole de l'information qui n'est pas
exactement
la démocratie
générale donc voilà c'est une conception
on peut avoir différentes conceptions de
la démocratie évidemment
ce type de problème existe dans chacun
de nos pays en Espagne il y a des
polémiques de cette nature depuis des
années des années des mesures qui sont
prises qui sont critiquées en France
n'en parlons pas alors l'occasion de
retraites des polémiques sur retraite on
a entendu la démocratie et effacer la
démarcation écrasée comme bien de fois
même sur cette plateau il y a des
interlocuteurs qui disaient ça dans
chacun de nos pays il y a des polémiques
sur les fonctionnellement de la
démocratie mais soyons sérieux la
démocratie italienne n'a pas été en
danger n'est pas en danger et ne serait
pas engagé moins que la démocratie
française
née dans la Résistance et le début de
ses premiers mandats n'est pas anodin et
le fait ce qu'il a réussi à faire
jusqu'à maintenant ce qu'il
comme le terrorisme qui ont menacé la
démocratie la démocratie italienne a été
plus solide et entendu une démocratie
solide on a entendu vous arguments à
l'une et à l'autre là-dessus je reviens
au duo et à la relation franco-italienne
dans la titré la mésentente cordiale je
vous propose une première réaction
extrait de l'intervention d'Emmanuel
Macron en cette fin d'après-midi juste
avant la rencontre avec Georgia Meloni
où il fait référence à l'histoire
finalement la grande Histoire
franco-italienne plus forte que les
petits citoyens pour reprendre
l'expression vous vous employez tout à
l'heure
qui était nos économies nos universités
nos artistes font aussi vivre chaque
jour
ce rapport si unique qui existe entre
l'Italie et la France c'est cette amitié
qui m'importe en premier lieu vous le
savez madame la Présidente du Conseil
celle qui permet de faire vivre parfois
les controverses et des accords mais
dans un cadre toujours respectueux parce
qu'il s'inscrit dans une histoire plus
grande que nous plus profonde qui a
nourri nos imaginaires nos artistes les
aventures collectives c'est bien le sens
du Traité du Quirinal alors on va tout
de suite entendre la réponse alors je
sais plus dans quel ordre c'était deux
Georgia Meloni sur ce même thème de
l'amitié franco-italienne en écoute la
chef du gouvernement
la France sont deux pays étroitement
liés ce sont deux pays protagonistes en
Europe de pays importants qui ont besoin
notamment à une époque comme celle-ci de
dialoguer parce que nos intérêts sont
multiples et sont convergents notre
collaboration est une collaboration
étroite une collaboration fructueuse
dans de nombreux domaines Marc Lazar je
reviens vers vous peut-être sur une
dimension un peu personnelle à quel
point
l'amitié ou l'inimitié entre deux chefs
d'État enfin la chef d'État chef de
gouvernement peut jouer parce qu'on dit
il y a un mouvement plus fort il y a des
intérêts économiques des intérêts
européens etc mais la relation le fait
que une relation entre deux chefs d'État
se noue à quel point ça peut jouer ah
bah bien sûr que ça joue ça joue à autre
chose à Belloni et Emmanuel Macron comme
ça joue entre d'autres chefs d'État ou
de gouvernement et dans le cas
d'Emmanuel Macron et dure jamais l'onise
c'est vraiment deux personnes totalement
différentes autant Emmanuel Macron et
Mario Draghi appartenaient au même monde
celui des élites internationales des
gens qui qui savent se parler qui
respectent les mêmes codes qui ont les
mêmes quasiment les mêmes formations
autant là on a deux personnalités
totalement différentes Emmanuel Macron
brillante élève
au fonctionnaires banquiers enfin comme
chante toutes les cases genre jamais
l'ONU venus d'un des quartiers de Rome
la garbaté la qui n'a pas fait d'études
supérieures ce qui n'empêche pas cette
jeune femme comme vous l'avez rappelé de
parler plusieurs langues d'avoir une
grande capacité politique donc
évidemment il n'y a pas de lien il n'y a
pas d'atomes crochus entre ces deux-là
tout le monde le sait il faut qu'ils
apprennent à travailler ensemble et et
c'est compliqué parce que ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est extraordinaire c'est
c'est toujours les mêmes formules
Emmanuel Macron avec tant d'autres après
tant d'autres présidents rappelle les
liens extraordinaires qui existent entre
la France et l'Italie les deux sœurs y
a-t-il les deux grands cousins et on
sait que très souvent il y a des
désaccords et il y en aura d'autres qui
ressurgiront et
de la mélodie très souvent on le sait à
une certaine aversion je pèse mes mots
une certaine en tout cas en avait une à
l'égard de la France il y a beaucoup
critiqué que la France le président de
la République vient de faire allusion
traité du Corinne la conférence de la
conférence de presse de fin d'année
Georgia Meloni
interrogé par la journaliste français
sur le traité de corinale a eu cette
réponse je ne l'ai pas lu je ne sais pas
ce qu'il y a dedans elle savait très
bien ce qu'il y avait dedans puisque son
parti a refusé de voter ce traité et
qu'elle l'avait dénoncé comme
antidémocratique et au service
uniquement des intérêts français et ça
c'était encore il y a quelques mois donc
ça bon là il y a nécessité fait loi il
faut s'entendre et il y a des désaccords
complets tu en as eu qu'est-ce que vous
me permettez de revenir un tout petit
peu sur le débat qui a opposé mais très
rapidement allez-y
très rapidement c'est très difficile
d'avoir une appréciation de frères
d'Italie parce que c'est un parti en
évolution qui a plusieurs strates il y a
la strat oui du fascisme oui aujourd'hui
en transformation en mutation avec cette
dimension de droite nationale
conservatrice
parfois traditionaliste radicale
nationale et c'est ça qui rend la
complexité et je pense que j'aurai un
jugement un peu plus nuancé que mon ami
Alberto je ne dis pas Alberto que la
démocratie est en danger mais il y a un
certain nombre de signaux effectivement
qui pourrait être préoccupants je sais
aussi qu'il y a des anticorps face aux
attentes à la démocratie et je voudrais
juste prendre un élément sociologique à
prendre en considération il faut se
rendre compte de ce qui s'est passé
Fratelli italien c'était 4% en 2018
aujourd'hui c'est 26% les gens de
fratelleritaglia pendant des décennies
pendant des années ont été considérés
comme des gens qui appartenaient un
ghetto une petite minorité dont tout le
monde se moquait beaucoup d'entre eux je
ne dis pas de genre déjà Meloni mais son
entourage et c'est un entourage là qui
est parfois qui a envie de prendre sa
revanche voilà ça revanche et ça et ça
ça peut être un danger ça ça peut être
un dangereux attends je termine je
termine mais ça il y a un contre-feu il
faut le dire c'est le président de la
République et c'est les institutions
italiennes et la société civile voilà
c'est cet équilibre qu'il faut avoir en
tête donc grâce à ce contrefeu grâce à
un ensemble d'équilibre de notre
Constitution la démocratie n'est pas en
danger marque les dangers par rapport au
fonctionnement des institutions et aussi
par rapport à la démocratie existe
partout et tu sais mieux que moi à quel
point dans le débat sur les retraites et
la façon parce qu'en Italie une loi si
importante n'aurait pas pu passer sans
un vote le Parlement et en France elle
est passée sans un vote de l'Assemblée
nationale or s'il te plaît ce type de
discours résiste partout et l'exemple
français montrent que dans la mesure où
les dangers
l'importance c'est justement les
contreforts
vraiment qu'on parle d'immigration mais
quand même un une petite question parce
qu'à Johanna parce qu'on évoque souvent
notamment sur ce plateau les démocraties
il libérales
il y en a qu'une qui se revendique comme
tel c'est là en gris
aucun risque avec ce pouvoir en Italie
l'Italie bascule pardon de remettre 20
centimes dans la machine Alberto Giorgio
mélodie a parlé a fait pendant un moment
elle avait les yeux doux pour
Victor Hormann qui est alors lui pour le
coup et nulle part politiquement en ce
moment sur la scène européenne puisqu'il
est il est plus dans aucun groupe il est
avec les non inscrit donc et elle a
coupé les ponts parce que Georgia Meloni
sur la scène internationale en tout cas
sur tout ce qui est le
la tête le Conseil européen il n'y a pas
une feuille de papier à cigarette elle
vote toutes les sanctions
ukrainiennes elle est pas pro Poutine
c'était Salvini et Berlusconi qu'il
était c'est également Orban donc sur ce
plan là je dis pas qu'elle a la majorité
de Fratelli qu'elle exprime pas la
majorité de Fratelli italien mais sur la
politique internationale elle a plutôt
passé son examen et donc maintenant il
faut rentrer un petit peu faut craquer
le vernis et elle est dans le dur parce
qu'en effet sur la sur le sur la
franco-italien là pour le coup si on
s'entend bien avec le président de la
République italienne qui était là il y a
qu'un jour pour l'inauguration de de
l'excellente exposition
quelle exposition
il a une grande partie de ces musées il
ne faut pas aller voir le musée bon
allez terminer vite parce que on a
besoin de se parler parce que la culture
on a parlé rapidement mais ça se veut un
petit peu l'équivalent du traité de
l'Élysée qu'on a signé avec l'Allemagne
pour habibocher des sociétés qui avaient
du mal à s'entendre donc je ne dis pas
que ça va être pareil mais ça donne
peut-être un élan espérons-le on verra
immigration comme promis un chapitre
là-dessus et je vous propose d'abord
d'écouter ce qu'on disait il y a
quelques minutes dans cette fin
d'après-midi Emmanuel Macron à
l'occasion de s'être rencontre avec
Georgia Belloni nous continuons de
connaître des drames en Méditerranée il
nous faut être en mesure d'organiser
plus efficacement l'asile et
l'émigrations en Europe en étant fidèle
à nos valeurs et là aussi je veux dire
que la coordination et le bon travail
entre nos deux pays doivent se
poursuivre nous voulons mieux travailler
avec les pays d'origine et de transit
pour éviter les flux entrants c'est la
politique que nous essayons de conduire
depuis six ans avec plusieurs réunions
qui se sont tenues ici avec certains de
vos prédécesseurs et d'autres collègues
européens il faut maintenant la
renforcer c'est d'ailleurs tout le sens
aussi de l'initiative Tunis contiennent
que j'évoquais à l'instant nous
souhaitons renforcer le contrôle de nos
frontières extérieures et j'accueille
Audrey beta sur ce plateau bonsoir
Audrey on va remonter le fil grâce à
vous de ces 8 mois depuis que Georgia
Meloni est arrivé au pouvoir avec
effectivement de grosses turbulences sur
ce thème de l'immigration oui ça a
commencé directement après l'arrivée de
Georgia Meloni au pouvoir fin octobre
2022 en cause ce bateau que vous allez
voir à l'image à l'image la chaîne
Viking avec à son bord 230 migrants
sauvés des eaux par des ONG à ce moment
l'Italie refuse de lui ouvrir ses ports
car elle estime qu'elle a déjà joué son
rôle elle a déjà accueilli quatre autres
navires elles controvient à ce moment-là
à de nombreuses règles internationales
un bras de fer s'engage alors avec la
France notamment paroxysme est atteint
quand Georgia Meloni sur un coup de
bluff remercie Paris d'accueillir le
bateau il n'en est rien Paris n'a pris
aucun engagement elle vient de se faire
forcer la main au vu de la situation
sanitaire et parce que les jours
avancent Paris ouvre finalement son port
de Toulon on représailles la France
remet en place les contrôles aux
frontières avec l'Italie le message est
très important on est dans l'espace
Schengen et l'épisode donne d'ailleurs
lieu à une passe d'armes assez sèche
entre Gérald Darmanin et Giorgia Meloni
écouté les autorités françaises ont pris
la décision à titre exceptionnel de
palier au comportement inacceptable du
gouvernement italien et d'inviter le
navire à rejoindre le port militaire de
Toulon il est évident qu'à effet
immédiat la France suspend l'ensemble
des relocalisations nos bénéfices de
l'Italie et appelle tous les autres
participants notamment l'Allemagne au
mécanisme européen de faire de même
un peu moins de 90 000 personnes sont
entrées en Italie en 2022 dans l'accord
sur les relocalisations 8000 personnes
sont censées être relocalisées en Europe
savez-vous combien ont été relocalisés
jusqu'à présent en France
la première passe d'armes c'est pas fini
on aura d'autres relations
franco-italienne n'avait pas commencé
sous les meilleurs augures elle va
devenir glaciale après une sortie de
Gérald Darmanin encore lui c'était début
mai toujours sur des questions
d'immigration le ministre est interrogé
après de très nombreuses interpellations
de personnes en situation irrégulière
dans les Alpes-Maritimes il rejette
alors la faute sur le gouvernement
nationaliste italien incapable de régler
le progrès problème migratoire d'après
lui et il ajoute je vais le citer Meloni
c'est comme Le Pen elle se fait élire
sur vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir et puisque l'on voit c'est que ça
ne s'arrête pas et que ça s'amplifie des
propos vous l'imaginez jugés
inacceptable par Rome qui dénonce une
insulte gratuite et vulgaire adressée à
un pays allié d'autant qu'il faut
souligner la situation est
exceptionnelle actuellement en
Méditerranée les flux migratoires en
direction de l'Italie ont été
multipliées par quatre par rapport à
l'an dernier Thomas merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces explications
sur cette question de l'immigration
comment les Italiens jugent le bilan de
de leur chef de gouvernement c'est un
peu tôt pour savoir évidemment voilà et
il faudrait des élections législatives
vraiment pour le savoir il y a eu
quelques élections peuvent partielles on
ne peut pas encore dire il y a une
inquiétude très clairement chez les
Italiens c'est une cette même inquiétude
qui a porté la coalition au pouvoir avec
les dernières élections
l'inquiétude elle est multiple alors
depuis plusieurs années et la Ligue du
Nord devenue League avait vraiment fait
un travail très très capillaire de
attaque contre les migrations
criminalisation contre les immigrés et
c'est assimilation criminelle délinquant
violeurs etc c'est un travail terrible
qui a été fait pendant des décennies qui
a laissé sa trace même chez des gens de
gauche donc voyez c'est vraiment quelque
chose de qui qui s'associe avec une
crise économique une un malaise que les
Italiens ressentent par rapport à leur
pouvoir d'achat
par rapport à la perte des filets de
sécurité sociaux par rapport à
laffaiblissement du droit du travail
aussi et avec Alberto Toscano ce
sentiment d'être abandonné par l'Europe
en particulier on peut dire ça
et aujourd'hui les opinion publique
italienne à
voter
démocratiquement une élection parce que
l'opinion publique italienne est
profondément dessus par l'attitude de
l'Europe et qui effectivement
donne cette sensation au pays
l'Italie mais aussi la Grèce
de l'Espagne aussi le Malte d'être
abandonné et dire que les migrants qui
n'ont pas vocation à rester en Europe et
doivent être ramenés dans leur pays
d'origine doivent être
accueilli dans le pays de premier
accueil l'Italie dans ce qui a reçu 57
000 migrants cette année depuis à
travers la Méditerranée et ensuite c'est
à l'Italie de décider et qui peut partir
quand même de jurer ce problème et de
les ramener c'est impossible les pays
des premiers accueil ne peuvent pas
gérer ce problème et latitude notamment
de la France et du ministre Darmanin
vis-à-vis de ce dossier qui a été
parfois inaptitude de provocation
vis-à-vis de l'Italie et pas seulement
avec ce gouvernement pas seulement cette
attitude n'aide pas à
désamorcer ce problème
très épidermique ça fait plusieurs
années avant George Jamel Oni et avant
que on a un problème on a en effet des
gens qui arrivent sur le territoire
plutôt au sud donc en effet l'Italie la
Grèce et l'Espagne et qui estime être un
peu laissé de faire le travail pour les
autres alors que ces étrangers vas-y
migrants ne veulent pas rester dans le
pays ok ils viennent d'arriver la
solution est européenne et c'est pour ça
qu'il était bien qu'elle se voit là tous
les deux là Giorgia Meloni et Macron
parce que au Conseil européen du 29 et
30 juin après moultes et moult
rebondissements le pacte européen sur la
Libération qui est un peu cuit quand
même peut-être arriver il manque un truc
politique donc le truc politique qui
peut venir que par l'échelle donc c'est
bien parce qu'en effet une position
commune un peu forte sur cette question
migratoire
forte on verra mais une position commune
parce que les gens sont les gens parfois
on voit bien c'est shikayas c'est
national etc ça ne mène à rien ça ça
crise peut les opinions publiques et
après on a les des commentaires dans la
presse que vous nous avez étonné mais la
seule solution est européenne oh il faut
pas il faut pas se masquer la France et
l'Italie partage plus de choses sur ce
sujet que d'autres pays d'Europe
centrale orientale qu'ils veulent voir
aucun migrants les Allemands qui disent
de toute façon nous on gérera parce que
Claire chaffendas comme il le disent
plus difficile sur les pays du Nord qui
ont eu des mailles à partir etc et puis
les Britanniques qui ont quitté l'Union
mais tout en quittant l'Union qui ont
quand même une pression migratoire parce
que les gens veulent partir aussi oui ça
ne peut être fait qu'au niveau européen
et si ça nous permet ça sera criminel
parce que on a les élections européennes
en avril juin 2024 et si on n'a pas
avancé sur ce sujet alors on va devant
de graves déconvenues dont on voit avec
Marc Lazar les tenants et aboutissants
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous dis à bientôt sur
public c'est